Speaker 1: In a new interview, the former
Donald Trump national security adviser, Michael
Flynn says that COVID was intentionally released
by people like George Soros, Klaus Schwab,
Bill Gates and others in order to further
their goal of ruling the world and controlling
humanity and defeating Donald Trump.
Of course.
We're going to look at a little bit of this.
This is this is from Infowars, and here's
what I really want you to think about as you
watch this and listen to this.
This man was the national security adviser
of the United States at one point, and that
was one point was not that long ago.
It was just a few years ago.
And this is what he is now saying.
Now I also want you to think about, is he
out of his mind or is he grifting and doesn't
believe this stuff?
I actually have an opinion, but I'm going
to tell you after we look at the clip, is
this for real or is he grifting?
That's the question.
Speaker 2: The World Health Organization,
which has come into, you know, into the news
quite a bit because of all this coverage stuff
and the responses.
But all of these global organizations, the
United Nations is another one.
All these global organizations.
They think they see themselves and those that
are sort of even above them.
They see themselves as this is how we can
rule the world.
This is how we can control societies.
This is how we can control humanity.
So let's introduce something called Coburn
introduce.
And they did it, and they did it for a couple
of reasons.
One of the big reasons was was to steal an
election.
I mean, if if the Democrats, you know, work
as hard on on us, on foreign policy as they
work on still in the elections, maybe we would
be better off.
Speaker 1: But now over the counter to that,
of course, is if Donald Trump had just dealt
with COVID, well, he would have sailed to
reelection, like so many other world leaders
did so.
COVID hurt Trump because he failed, but many
world leaders succeeded and sailed to easy
reelections.
Speaker 2: You know, so so there's I mean,
there's a lot of things here going on.
But yes, these are these are globalist organizations.
These are world organizations.
And when you start to look at, you know, who
is who is directing them and who is leading
them.
There are real people behind that.
And I, you know, I mean, Schwab is one you
got a, you know, George Soros.
You have the the Arabella Group.
I mean, these are real things.
These are real led by real people who are
who have placed themselves.
You know, Gates is another one who have placed
themselves above some of the some of these
world institutions.
And they drive them, they really do drive
them.
Speaker 1: So this is just about the craziest,
most unhinged hypothesis anyone could come
up with about COVID.
And Soros and Gates and Klaus Schwab from
the World Economic Forum.
Now again, without a doubt, the mental illness
explanation would surface here, right?
Any more or less normal person who watches
this would consider, Is this a propaganda
spreader?
Or is this a psychotic break and when you
see weaponized Trumpism, it can be genuinely
difficult to discern conspiracy ism from someone
experiencing a psychotic break, that's a reality.
It's quite a reality.
And we saw that in the clips of the people
being interviewed at the Trump rally in the
last segment.
But but I think that Flynn is grifting.
I think Flynn is definitely grifting here.
That's my instinct.
I believe that Michael Flynn is doing this
to drum up.
I mean, listen, where is he going to get support?
He is obviously not going to get it from the
sane left.
You might find some wacky people on the left,
supposedly on the left, like I'm not even
going to name people, but some of the usual
suspects that have sort of gone off the deep
end on the left.
Maybe they would see someone like Flynn and
be like, This guy's willing to tell the truth,
but basically the left is not going to support
him.
The establishment right is not going to support
him because even though he was pardoned, this
guy was convicted.
He did absolutely horrible things.
So much of the right's not going to support
him, either.
So the concerted the potential constituency
for someone like Michael Flynn to make money
from and to get speaking gigs is going to
be the QAnon type conspiracy theory.
So my instinct is that his wacky.
But that he doesn't believe this stuff and
that this is a grift.
The crazy part, though, is that there are
many people who will watch this and hear him
talk about it and they'll go, Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
George Soros is responsible for COVID that
that makes a lot of sense to me.
They'll not along to it, and that's an extraordinarily
disturbing thing.